Now you've seen this code that calculates the sum of the digits
of the number. But we promised that this code for iterating over
each digit in a number would be useful for validating credit card
numbers, and here's why. When you write down a credit card number, it's
really easy to switch two numbers. And that's pretty annoying for somebody
who is trying to charge your credit card so you can buy things.
Luckily, the designers of credit card numbers back in the day thought
about this. All credit card numbers have to follow a kind of pattern.
And there's an algorithm that uses the pattern to figure out
if the customers has accidentally switched 2 numbers. That algorithm has
a very similar structure to the code for summing digits. Let
me write the pseudo code for this algorithm, so we can
compare this algorithm with the one for validating credit cards. When
we trace this code, we saw that it set N and
Sum, and then for each digit in N; starting with the
one on the right, it added the digit to the Sum.
And then at the end it printed the Sum, now here's a question; which of these
lines of code is responsible for making sure
that the code looks at each digit in N?